en banlieue de quieve c'est un refuge
pour animaux pas comme les autres
il a été abandonné par ses maîtres nous
avons été alertés par les militaires qui
l'ont trouvé comme toujours dans ce
genre de cas il vivait dans une volière
de 2 mètres sur 3 avec un sol en béton
[Musique]
sauvages en captivité est interdit mais
parfois pratiqué en Ukraine depuis
l'invasion russe à grande échelle cette
ONG a sauvé plus de 200 mètres comme
celle-ci
alors que leur maître avait fui les
combats
les tigres et les ours cette guerre est
aussi on peut dire la chance d'avoir une
vie normale mais pour la faune sauvage
c'est une véritable catastrophe quand un
missile tombe il n'y a plus rien de
vivant dans son rayon les animaux autour
subissent les commotions cérébrales on
ne peut plus rien faire pour eux ils
fuient il se cache et meurt lentement
dans des souffrances terribles
de la guerre pour l'environnement à 40
milliards de dollars et ce chiffre va
exploser avec la libération de
territoire nous ne pouvons pas constater
chez moi
Olena est député elle fait partie d'un
groupe de travail chargé par l'État
ukrainien d'étudier l'impact de la
guerre sur la nature
aujourd'hui ce territoire est
entièrement libéré mais cet héritage est
critique pour l'environnement toutes les
ressources naturelles sans exception les
airs les sols les nappes phréatiques les
milieux marins toutes subissent des
conséquences très graves les ponts les
habitations nous reconstruirons tout
cela très vite avec l'aide
internationale mais réparer la nature
nous ne pourrons pas le faire le citron
est très difficile à estimer le jour où
elle sera finie les écologistes estiment
qu'il faudra encore des dizaines
d'années avant que la nature ne reprenne
ses droits